[تصفيق]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم مع ارتفاع الاصابات
بكرونا تصاعد الاحتجاجات الشعبيه في الصين
على قيود الاغلاق الحكوميه وسياسه صفر
كورونا المظاهرات تبدو الى العاصمه بجين
ومدينه شنغهاي اهم المراكز التجاريه
بالبلاد عقب حريق اسفر عن مصرعي عشره
اشخاص في مبدا باورنج عاصمه اقليم
تركيا تعلن مواصله عملياتها العسكريه ضد
من سمتهم الارهابيين في شمال سوريا
والعراق وحزب العمال الكردستانيه يقول ان
القصفه التركيه شامله مطار منه ومناطقه
عده في الرقه وحلب وروسيا تتحدث عن خلافات
مع انقره بشان سوريا مؤكده ان العلاقات
الجيده بينهما تسمح بتسويتها عبر
المحادثات
معارك و قصف متبادل في شرقي اوكرانيا
وجنوبها السلطات المواليه لروسيا في
دونيست تؤكد سقوط ضحايا في قصف الاوكرانيا
على احياء سكنيه وسط المدينه والجيش
الاوكراني يقول ان قصفا روسيا مكثفا
استاذفا البنيه التحتيه في مقاطعه دنيبر
وسط البلاد
منتخب كوستاريكا يحقق فوزا مهما على
اليابان بهدف دون مقابل في الجوله الثانيه
لمباريات المجموعه الخامسه وهو الفوز الذي
فتح التنافس على التاهل الدوري القادم بين
منتخبات المجموعه التي تضم ايضا اسبانيا
والمانيا وكانت اسبانيا قد تغلبت على
كوستاريكا بسبعه اهداف دون مقابل في
الجوله الاولى الى اللقاء